we have like 20 pounds of dough for this
donut
i don't think this table is big enough i
think it's time to go big or go home
this is the biggest note i've ever seen
[Music]
hi my name is alvin i'm a tasty producer
and i love making big food so yesterday
i got an instagram message from a
bodybuilder with a handle no donuts here
and he says hey dude
i have an idea i saw the giant burger
video and tomorrow is my cheat day
i was wondering if you could make me a
giant donut oh man
that sounds crazy how big big
gotta eat big to get big awesome that's
what i like to hear
hit me up tomorrow and i'll see what i
can do and i've also been getting a lot
of requests to make a
giant donut so i feel like i know what
i'm gonna make today
how are you yeah nice to see you yeah
likewise for the people that don't know
you
what do you do i am a cop cop slash
fitness person i've been a cop for over
11 years now but i've used
social media as a platform to encourage
first responders live healthier
lifestyles what is the story behind your
social media
my handle is no doughnuts here kind of
poking fun at the
donut eating cop stereotype you want to
command presents and look professional
you know fitness plays a huge part in
that
what is your relationship with food it
has a lot to do with whether you're
storing fat
building muscle cheat day is mostly to
keep you sane drop your carbs down
really low and
you want to have a doughnut to fill you
out yeah make you feel good sounds like
today is your cheat day have you worked
out today yet
not yet how about i go make the big
donut if you want to go work out and
have a very fun cheat meal for you
sounds like i'll need that workout all
right cool thanks dude i'll see you in a
bit all right
let's make this big donut for a big man
first thing we're going to do we're
gonna have to make the donut dough
is a yeasted donut so we're gonna start
by making the yeast mixture some milk
some warm water some sugar
and the yeast oh i just spilled a little
bit that's okay this yeast is just gonna
soak up
all this nice sugar all this nice milk
really grow into a big boy
see you in a bit so this donut takes a
lot of flour and
my mixing bowl is only this big so i'm
actually gonna be making
two entire batches of this dough ten
entire cups of flour
[Music]
this is a white cloud some salt
shortening four eggs hook this up to the
dough mixer
delicious yeast mixture oh god i'm
spilling everywhere
accidents happen that's fine stay clean
so the funny thing is
even one of these batches makes about 20
to 30 donuts
and i'm doubling it so there's going to
be enough dough for
like 40 to 60 donuts i think it's time
to go big or go home
i really don't want to go home whoa look
at all that dough let's get you out of
here
put it into this big bowl this is the
biggest bowl we have in the tasty
kitchen
get out of there come on dude it's the
most i've held in my entire life
i would not be a good rapper okay gluten
coming through that's only one we gotta
make another batch
i told my mom i was gonna go make that
dough
i don't think she knew that this is what
i meant we have like
20 pounds of dough in here for this
donut
that was fun these gluten strands are
like super tight right now we want them
to relax
i'm gonna go in and take a long nap for
the big times all right
i will see you and i will see you in a
bit
now let's make the glaze for the donut
so the glaze is pretty simple we just
have some
melted butter it's kind of a lot of
butter but more butter more better
funny thing is the original glaze recipe
makes enough for about
10 to 15 donuts we're making a really
big one so i tripled the recipe i think
this batch of pink glaze is going to be
enough for
30 to 45 normal donuts so the butter is
melted we're gonna add in some
milk three cups of powdered sugar
that cloud reminds me of something else
snow so
uh there's a lot of lumps got a nice
whisk here whip it through the glass
looking pretty nice that strippage going
on here so at this point we're gonna add
the color
literally the ingredient is the color
pink i hope this is pink hold on
oh okay that's pink we're good one drop
of the color pink
oh i added two look at that
two drops did that i said that's pretty
pink
deliciousness right there can't have a
giant donut without giant sprinkles for
reference
these are normal rainbow sprinkles this
is the size of one sprinkle do you guys
know how sprinkles are made
because i sure did it before this i'm
going to take some powdered sugar some
corn syrup
some corn starch and some water
i think that's literally it sprinkles
have colors i have like
10 bajillion things of food coloring
here so we're going to divide this
into 10 bajillion bowls and then we're
going to color it one two three
four five came through dripping drip
drip
got red yellow green blue
yo blue what's going on man blue i don't
want too much i just need a little bit
all right there's blue
and purple all right yellow you better
represent us well oh
that's looking nice boom purple's done
so warm them all up a little bit
and i need to get uh each color
individually into the piping bag so a
little trick
take a cup put your piping bag with the
tip in it like that
transfer the glaze see if this works
that's so cool that feeling when you're
like cutting through paper in
kindergarten
and you just glide right on with the
scissors
that's what this feels like next color
we're gonna pick up where i left off
train number two blue i love that
last but not least purple all right i
know you really can't see it but
this is the size of one sprinkle
this is quite the size difference i'll
let these dry out and
i'll see you in a bit all right let's
see how big my dough has gotten
sweet baby jesus look at this one he
went like straight through puberty
and hit menopause get the flower
here we go come on let's get out of
there oh
damn look at that gluten
look at you i'm gonna work it a little
bit i'm gonna knock some of the air out
of it
and then we're going to get it back into
a ball shape it's got some weight to it
look at this absolute unit right there
it's tucked underneath lebron james this
guy is going to relax for a bit
and then we are going to shape them into
an actual donut so one thing that i
should have probably thought about was
how big this donut is gonna be
so this is the biggest pan we actually
have i don't think this pan is gonna cut
it i have a friend who's a chef nearby
i'm hoping that he has something bigger
so let me message him and see what he
says
like hey super random question but what
is the size of your biggest pan
i got a stupid big walk it's 30 inches
five dollar bill for reference
holy moly i'm coming over 30 inches
is the entire width of this table so his
walk is gonna be like
this big so i gotta turn this ball of
dough into a perfect doughnut ring
bye baby this is kind of fun i've never
really had to use my forearms to
knead before just start in the middle
and work your way outwards
okay how are we looking yeah that's not
big enough i don't think this table is
big enough gotta get him into
a circle i'm gonna interlock these two
ends over here
birds and the bees am i right now i
gotta figure out how to transport this
all the way to the restaurant
large piece of cardboard covered in
parchment paper and taped together in
the back so here we go
let's go for it all right we can reshape
it that's okay
all right you little let's get over here
we're gonna cover this
in plastic wrap and then we're gonna
head over to the restaurant all right
can someone call me an uber
[Music]
30 inches where'd you get this i got in
chinatown oh
[Music]
300 degrees you gotta go lower
yeah how long do you think we should fry
this before before we flip it
uh i think give it another like four
more minutes how are we gonna flip this
error
somebody uses two tongs okay and then
somebody uses
two of the ladles do not do this at home
this is very dangerous he is a skilled
professional
this is heavy yeah oh it's like uh
here can it go deeper under it oh god i
punctured it
i think we need a better tool
oh okay
[Applause]
oh sh oh i don't know if it's gonna stay
together
yeah me neither that was a good
technique though maybe we should have
submerged it
i think we can get it to work so i'm
gonna make another batch
we're not gonna let this go to waste
yeah let's chop it up and make it into a
breakfast
okay do you wanna use it yeah i'll take
it all right cool we'll see you in a bit
guys
eric i made another donut round two here
we go fingers crossed
let's do it it's going in yep all right
beautiful so this goes in okay we're
gonna submerge it to make sure that it
can cook
and you can cook more evenly yeah yes
let's do this and then we'll press it
down
with heavy stuff we have a textbook
textbook plates
two on each side this is a very uh diy
situation it's called
problem solving this is what columbia
university doesn't teach so i think this
is gonna cook for
what like 20 25 minutes let's check back
in a bit to see if we can flip it this
is looking pretty good if you look at it
it looks really beautiful super super
crispy
we are going to try a super hard task of
flipping it because last time this is
where i feel
alright let's take off these weights one
two
three all right whoa dude this thing's
huge
wow this is a nice nice doughnut a
little white spot in the back uh we're
going to cook it once it flipped over
and then i'll trim off any that doesn't
look good all right get out of there
i just want to see how heavy this is
oh the hella heavy let's do the tray
method all right
okay so we're gonna get under here can
you help me get this onto the tray yes
yes oh look at it look at how solid that
oh
here we go
you got it you got it yeah okay
so whoa look at that oh
let's go yes this is crazy we did it
look at that that's awesome
looks like a cross between a bagel and a
donut this is the biggest no-no i've
ever seen
this is the homer donut it's a big zero
because that's how many calories there
are
don't think that's how it works you get
on oh
great nice job eric all right i got the
back
go yes okay we got it yep all right cool
careful the hot oil coming in go and
tray underneath
beautiful gotta do some asmr hold on
hello today
we'll be exploring a giant
donut i'm not doing that ever again all
right thanks dude see you man have a
good one
bye best of luck all right we are back
and we are going to make this big donuts
get my sprinkles
i made some white sprinkles because i
forgot to do that and after seeing how
big the donut was
i doubled how much glaze i have all i
need to do is cut these giant sprinkles
into
their shape and we can finally glaze and
sprinkle the donut
[Music]
damn that's a nice sprinkle right here
i accidentally hit someone with this
this might be salt with a deadly weapon
more like salt with delicious weapon all
right these sprinkles are ready to go i
think it's time to glaze this donut make
sure there's no
lumps you're looking good this might get
messy
[Music]
damn look at this glaze waterfall so we
got to put on the sprinkles before
everything starts to set all the colors
i think this is done
here we go hey mike yeah do you want
your donut
oh i'm ready all right close your eyes
we're coming this is so heavy
we needed two people to lift it one
two three open your eyes no
way are you kidding me this is what you
uh
expected when i said i was gonna make
you a dinosaur i wasn't thinking this
big this is insane
pick this got to be 20 30 pounds a cut
piece for you
oh man that's like three donuts right
there
[Music]
this is for you all right cheers mike
cheers happy cheat day yeah
[Music]
good it was pretty good it's perfect
crispy on the outside
soft on the inside icing is great a lot
of cheat days coming up
that's real good i might have to take
this whole thing home
thanks dude thank you guys
all right bye mike bye guys all right
have a good one yeah
see you later see you later so that will
probably be the biggest donut i will
ever see
or make in my entire life i love making
these crazy things so if you have a
favorite food if you have an idea that
you want me to try to make huge
hit me up leave a comment send me an
instagram message and i will see if i
can make that big for you
if you actually want to go to
restaurants that serve these crazy
things
my friend jasmine has a giant food
series on bring me that is really really
cool so you should go check it out
until next time peace
[Music]
you